I just want to take a pill and play with
my dreams lucid dreaming is where you
are aware that you're dreaming while
you're dreaming so then you can kind of
like have some sort of control over like
oh I know it's a dream so now I'm gonna
like fly around I know it once I'm in it
I just didn't help to make myself do it
if I had a lucid dream
I would probably sleep with someone who
I know I'll probably never meet probably
a celebrity or something what is dream
life so it's the most advanced lucid
dreaming supplement on the planet it
activates neurotransmitters it will
enhance my dream recall it will promote
balance to sleep so you can have
incredibly vivid memorable lucid dreams
take one balute capsule immediately
before going to bed set your alarm to
wake up after four hours of sleep take
one red capsule and begin dreaming Oh
see if I wake up in the night and take a
pill sleep
it's Monday night I am about to take my
very first blue pill see how it goes
just
I was dreaming before you don't so last
night was the first night I didn't have
any different sleep than I usually do I
came home like at 2:00 in the morning I
still took my pill tonight
better results we fell time for the red
pill and did not have any cool dreams
it's a night of look night and I woke up
to take my pill also you can't see me
because it's dark I wasn't gonna try and
turn the light on so much of Reims I
really do hope tonight I get to fly okay
day two and nothing happened again so
this is the third night of the pills and
the last two nights I have actually had
like really bad sleep like I do in
general anyway where this was worse
sometimes yo I had a dream kind of crazy
I definitely hooked up with someone and
that's like not a person that I'm like
interested in but I wasn't bad so one of
the dreams I had lost my axe you were
quite well like probably more normal I
did technically dream last night where
like some guy and who I thought was like
his mom but I think later it was like
his wife were like at a fancy dinner and
they were arguing but then he surprised
over the bottle of wine and they stopped
arguing and then I will go
thanks pills I had like so many same
dreams I remember one specifically where
I came to my friend's house and she was
just like accidentally spilling buckets
of blood all over her carpet I got in
sex with unexpected people where you're
like oh I never saw you in that light
but y'all right I'm not a creep I sir
I'm like actively dreaming now we're
just all I'm asking for that's all I'm
after here is I want to have cool movie
dreams I've definitely been having more
vivid dreams that I remember
as far as lucid dreaming goes I haven't
had any of that and I'm really sad about
it
dreaming three nights in a row like
doesn't happen for me something has
changed when the real X Factor is these
pills
[Music]
[Music]